before you start miss jim
we never
passed the
recommendation on item one
correct
oh
yep
yes we're
right
let's continue handy to you aaron
yeah thank you youtuber um
so um since our last committee meeting
um
the contractors had been affected by 23
week days
where no work's been able to take place
on the main trench
it's been a couple of health and safety
instances
that have happened um
one of them's quite minor um
during an audit site visit that i was at
um
noticed that one of the staff members
was inside a manhole without any ppe
so they rectified that fairly smartly
and yeah so we're working pretty closely
with them at the moment
and he's satisfied with the progress to
date
uh it's at the moment they're currently
in the deepest section so things are a
lot slower than um what they envisioned
and and what council we didn't had
envisioned
um so
um
there is currently we're going through a
um
revised
um plan with them to
find out when
we plan to finish the project so it's
going to be finishing a bit later than
schedule
i see you've appointed or
selected some uh
a group of plumbers to do the private
connect connections which seems to be an
important milestone i would think yes so
um through that um private property
separation we now have elected um a
panel of three
local plumbers uh so there is gore elite
plumbing called southern plumbing and
heating and shed and plumbing um that
will carry out that
private property separation
um currently
i have
five proposals for the first five
properties
that are going through cost analysis now
and approval process for consents
um so that's starting at the brenton
street end working their way along so
that's going to move along quite nicely
thank you i'll
open it for questions from the committee
members
[Music]
do a first visit um ascertain how the
private property will be separated
then the plumber will go away and and
come up with a plan and a costing and
then i'll go and have an on-site meeting
with the property owner
and seek their approval for that work to
carry out and get them to sign an
agreement
um where we
um
will agree on any reinstatement
if there's any trees that need to be
removed or
all that sort of thing um and when the
work starts we take photos before
so that there's no discrepancies on of
anything um and same when it's finished
so
yeah so far we haven't had any issues so
yeah
if it's all right i'll just add to um
what aaron's saying yeah um
so
um
since the report's been written um and
and last
last week um
fort hogan did have a reasonably um
serious near-miss on site where a digger
tipped over
and as a result of that
we stopped work on site
and reviewed
the construction methodology that they
were using and have amended that to make
sure that the work can be completed
safely
[Music]
and as of today we're now happy with
with the revised work methodology and
and uh getting work back underway um but
that has delayed
um the progress that it's
particularly the area that they're
working through now is is proving to be
quite challenging because of the depth
and the ground conditions and things
but they are certainly particularly
following the recent incident
taking things pretty cautiously and and
making sure that they do it safely
[Music]
i guess to add to that
so that that's sort of been a relative
the progress over the last
three or four weeks has been pretty slow
because of those complications
and they have been affecting the
driveways of
about three properties
during that time um so they've had an
extended period where they haven't
had access to their property vehicle
access to their property
but we are
keeping in close contact with them and
making sure that
we can do what we whatever we can do
thank you matt
um
after a discussion with you it sounds
like it is a complex a complex process
something i didn't actually appreciate
so
it's um
to use your words
challenging piece of work and at five
meter depth and bit of danger involved
in weather conditions so
i guess it is what it is i see we're
probably about 35 through our budget um
you're quite
it's probably too early to
ask you uh where we're going to end up
but you're happy at the moment we're
tracking as we should do
uh yeah
so far everything's tracking where we
should be so no concerns there
thank you i guess uh
um there'll be an update the next
committee meeting uh
more questions
okay we'll uh
one question oh mike how are you welcome
yes mike yeah we'll take your question
now
my question relates to given the health
and safety issues
how do we
capture those
and make sure that
um so there's been a full investigation
um
carried out by
fortin hogan
um and
we've been um privy to a lot of that
information through reports
um through our um through matt and
myself and the engineers
um and
a lot of that is being relayed back into
our own health and safety um recording
database
so that that can be captured for future
reference as well
so hopefully that answers that
that's true the second question
and it's taken is because of the bad
weather have we
kept communicating with them or
have we relied on them to observe that
they no longer have access to their
property
um we had asked that fort and hogan kept
in close contact with the
property owners
so
it's something that we've relayed a
number of times with with the contractor
so
there's uh
yes those complaints would come directly
to me
good questions michael thank you very
much and welcome uh john
through the chair um yeah i guess it's
it's the
contractors responsibility to ensure the
work is completed safely um so i guess
that issue
sits with the contractor
um
yeah i mean
to be honest i've never been through a
situation where a contractor's tried to
claim for costs around that sort of
delay um and i'd have to work through
the contract details
but ultimately i think
it sits with the contractor and they
need to make sure that it's done safely
um steve you might want to add this
ferry yeah it actually works in reverse
um through this chair that uh
i haven't seen matt and aaron martin
be able to tell me but often there is a
provision for liquidator damages
for late delivery of the project and
then for the
client
if it can prove reasonable loss can
charge
the fixed amount per day specified in
the contract for late delivery
any more comments questions
neville are you assuming i believe
there's an article in target today is
there in regards to that
yeah
yeah i think there is a feature that's
correct
but given it was a it is a relatively
flat site tipping the digger over there
must have been lifting something to he
or something because you wouldn't tip a
digger over on a flat side just
um
given the
um
unstable ground
the five metre depth that they're
digging at
the fact that
[Music]
they are
were backfilling um it made for
a pretty complicated worksite
and
they were also working over a trenched
lateral so yeah it sort of
was
some complicated situation that occurred
right
any more questions or comments
just if i can attempt to say that uh i
have uh when this incident occurred
had direct dialogue with the regional
manager of fulton hogan um
and it certainly was taken very
seriously at the highest levels
to get matters right
and
and obviously we wanted to make sure
that the revised methodology was signed
off uh before the stock work notices
were uplifted
thank you mr perry
um
would someone be prepared to move that
we received that report please thank you
stuart those in favor please sign
seconded by john those in favor please
say hi against it carried we'll go back
to item one i'll move that we uh accept
that report which was the capital
project register secretary neville thank
you
uh all those in favor please say hi
again that's carried
item three wooden street
waste water mains replacement update
there's been a significant amount of
work over a long period of time and now
from reading the report there's
some issues going under
well not necessarily issues but
have to go under the railway lines and
through private property which will
uh
require some negotiation and timing with
other people um as i understand that the
work to date has gone very well
and i'll hand over to you matt for some
comment please
yeah thank you mr chairman yeah so this
um
we obviously completed stage two um
earlier this year um
and i've been working on the design of
stage three
um for the last few months um
it's a really complicated section of
wasteful domain to replace because it it
passes through private property
the rail corridors the state highway and
the hardwood street playground
but design is is going reasonably well
there's probably two significant
or two main issues that we're working
through at the moment
one is to get the the easement
required
to go through private property we've
been in contact with a couple of
landowners regarding that
and hopefully
expecting to take a report to council at
the um at the next council meeting
with some recommendations
regarding obtaining the necessary
easement that we need for for the
project
the other
um
i guess issue that we're monitoring
pretty closely is is um the fact that
kiwi rail we've got a um a project in
the same area um to upgrade the railway
siding
and so we're trying pretty hard to align
the projects and make sure that
we don't have to rip up their brand new
tracks
it is proving a little bit difficult
but at this stage we're hopeful that we
can align the projects
i'm happy to take any questions
i've got a question uh mr harry
um
the recommendation is that we receive
the report but at the end of this report
there's an additional recommendation
that um
1.75 million of funding be allocated to
the 2324 financial year to undertake
this work that that is brought forward
now is is this
um actually just for air information and
should be dealt with by full council or
um just wondering why that is there
um through mr chair it's it ultimately
will be determined by the full council
these minutes and recommendations go
through to full council
so um
i mean apart from the
i can't state the reason why the
recommendation there but really it's
just it's for completeness in terms of
realigning our budgets to actually
uh complete this work in a timely way
and to obviously coincide with cube
rails which program
right so if we receive the report the
report will then go to full council and
that recommendation as to the financial
will then be considered with full
council so that's just the implication
of that
sorry i should have mentioned that um in
my introduction but um the reason behind
that um is originally we'd plan to do
this
work in the
2023-24 financial year but to allow us
to align it with the kiwi rail project
we need to bring that funding forward
into the 22-23 financial year so
yeah sorry i should have mentioned that
earlier
i notice referring to a traffic light
system there is no
lights other than green
indicating that we're on track and
you're satisfied
with how things are going fine any
questions from the committee or further
comments
thanks mr chair um matt pretty exciting
stage three where is that going to end
is that over in hardwood street is it
through the chair yes it will finish at
the intersection of um hardwork and echo
street and then that'll be stage four
after that
yeah so there'll be there'll need to be
a further stage at hardwood street um
it's that there's two water mains that
run up there um and we need to look at
uh we'll probably need to look at
stormwater up there as well so yeah
the stage three is the most most
critical part really when we're coming
across all that
yeah it would certainly be pretty
problematic if um if we had a failure
under one of those key areas
so
yeah this is certainly the high priority
and
i guess once we get this completed we
can stop and recess and look at the next
stage yeah yeah these stages will be
good but um yeah getting underway with
the main trunk so yeah township happy
thoughts thank you mr and i i'd just
like to uh congratulate the staff on
uh pre-thinking about the whole project
and also being involved um
with nzta and keeping them away from
sealing the road etcetera and
aligning things in a timely
and
probably a financial benefit for us
would someone like to move that we
received the report
counselor
no certainly
not would you like to move or we receive
the port moved by john second to please
sue mcdonald
all those in favor please say hi
again stats care
item number four gore and matera
waste water consent
renewal
project
um
this is one of those um
very important issues
with some certain
potential for some complication when
you're having to deal with other parties
and seek their approval but
i know from the report council is moving
on with the best advice
that it can receive and we seem to be
hitting
well
would you like to give us an overview
and then i think i'll refer to mr
perry as far as their consenting yes
[Laughter]
for a guarantee about the consenting
thank you mr chairman
um yeah so since the last committee
meeting um parallel delamar partners
have been busy working away
on their long list options assessment
um they've certainly been requesting a
lot of information and talking to us a
lot about
our existing data and things
unfortunately they had hoped to have the
long list options assessment completed
by now
but but there's been some delays in
getting that done
so we have had a discussion
with them around making sure that we we
keep on track with this project
obviously
um
yeah there's some critical dates in
there and it is a pretty long time frame
um pdp are very confident that they can
catch up the time and and still make
that that ultimate deadline of um
october 23 in terms of identifying the
preferred option
um there is a
workshop planned
a technical working group meeting
planned for next week
to discuss pdp's initial
findings
so that will be quite interesting and
then following that they'll produce a
report around the long list options
assessment
um i guess the other thing to mention is
with with the estimated costs we are
expecting to to go slightly over budget
when compared to the original long-term
plan budgets
however there's probably not a lot of
certainty around that at this stage and
and we're expecting as the the options
assessments are completed we will get
more certainty
so
we'll sort of provide updates around
that as as the project progresses
thank you just for the
for the benefit of those people um
looking at their live stream this is
has its own unique complications and and
as much as the rma
[Music]
um dictates that we must have uh
cultural input from from uh
local uh to air um
ability to discharge
waste water into the material river
which has been our practice so there's
been consultation with uh with the
runanga the um intention in the in the
initial stages is to invest over time
considerable length of time between 50
and 60 million and upgrading
the on-site treatment of that
wastewater and then there's some
discussion as to
how it can be discharged and there's a
committee to consider the options one of
those options will be discharged to land
and there'll be variations on those
themes so it will be a work in progress
with uh with local cultural interests
and i'll ask the chief executive
have you got comment
yes thanks mr chairman look i think this
is this project is indicative
of the fact that matters have changed
we
have a as best as i can understand it
a
spiritual connection with
the river and do not like at all i find
it repugnant the concept of waste water
going into a food source
and so
land-based disposal is the best i'm
aware still the preferred option
and
this is this this process i believe will
result in
a dramatic change in the way that the
council treats its and views the way it
treats his wastewater
whether we get to participate in the
process fully or whether three waters
reforms
arrives and takes the issue off our
table is a moot point but
all the signs point to a serious
inquisition
as to how the council treats its
wastewater
and a marked improvement and of course
uh it's not just ew it's the
the consenting authority is operating
and a heightened um
national policy statement for fresh
water
and there is
a deep-seated ambition to improve river
water quality in our rivers so this is
all
going into the melting pot and out of
that you can definitely expect
a stricter regime for treatment of
wastewater
thank you miss perry so as you'll
appreciate it's a multi-layered
uh endeavor
over a long period of time
but
let's look at it positively the end
result will be an improvement on what we
currently
have accepted
and we have a little bit of time up at
sleeve any questions or comments from
staff and from committee members
[Music]
project and we want it done
reasonably quickly
but if it goes over the three waters
deadline
then
as those little report there's going to
be a re-look by the entity in terms of
priorities
but equally there could be a
renegotiation
of the terms of the project by any of
the
parties we've got
how we
if we take some action now
how do we make sure that that action is
finalized and agreed and non-negotiable
deadline because if it goes after that
we lose control and it could be
completely renegotiated
that's a difficult one so we better pass
that on miss perry
thank you steven um yeah good good
question michael i see this as a
different category that your question is
well put
and applies a lot in regard to
infrastructure improvement so the
previous item we talked about before
regarding and council grant asked about
the ongoing improvements to our trunk
domain from ending up of our book street
that's infrastructural improvement
and yes it has an indirect uh
impact and benefit to
what ultimately comes out at the end in
terms of treatment this is part of a
consented process and now we are into a
slipstream of a process we've applied
for a resource consent to environment
southland and we're in the earlier
phases of the consideration of that
consent i don't see
any um
intervention of a three waters reform
and the creation of a new entity being
able to influence
how
certainly the maybe how we get there but
the the fact that we're in this process
uh other parties have got
a legislative right to be involved
and that there is also the national
policy statement fresh water they will
ultimately influence the outcome so i
don't see
that we will lose control necessarily i
think we will we've already created the
control by pushing the go button and the
go button had to be pushed because our
resource consent has expired or just
about to expire
thank you
comments questions
uh
would somebody like to move or receive
this report thank you
stuart
seconded john all those in favor please
say aye against it's carried
and this will be
the next item
dear to neville's heart
matera water treatment plant
upgrade
and the associated um
[Music]
report there an upgrading of the
historical
facility in matera
i'll hand over to staff to give us a uh
lead us through
yes thank you
um so um on this one um we've just
finished um our tendering process
um so we're currently reviewing those at
the moment
um
so um
so no physical work's actually taken
place on site
um
and
we hope to um have the tender review
um before council on the 20th of
september
um
and
yeah that's about it if there's any
questions
can you just give us just a quick
overview as the actually what the
physical work will
yeah so um
the work to be carried out is to bring
the treatment plant up to drinking water
standards so there will be
a refurbishment of the treatment plant
a filter
upgrade of the
filters
raw
water uh
tank upgrade
um some pipe work a full electrical
upgrade um proposed uv
um
i think that's about it yeah thank you
and the approved budget for that work is
uh two and a quarter million um
i guess we've also got the other issue
in the background of us where source
water is and the piping for water and i
know it's not on the edge end of it have
you got a brief comment here we might
approach that
or is that
probably an easy question to ask but
difficult to answer
through you mr chairman um
yes obviously um
we prior to getting into the detailed
design of this project we look at looked
at some different options
which would allow us to move away from
using the pleura dam as our primary
water source um predominantly supplying
matera from gore and also working with
uh the alliance meatworks to um
have a joint source directly from the
material river unfortunately
those options
didn't work out predominantly because of
the large capital cost
we have also done a reasonable amount um
of drilling and
other investigation work to try and find
alternative water sources around matera
in close vicinity to the treatment plant
which hasn't come up with anything too
promising
um
particularly with the i guess the volume
of water that we need
um and the fact that we need
um control around that
section of land to make sure that
you know we don't have
contamination issues and things like
that
[Music]
so i guess predominantly
at this stage we're looking to use the
pluridam as our primary source with the
matera river as a
secondary source
as part of the upgrade
we are
changing the media filter and the new
media filter will have an improved
ability to treat for taste and odor
issues and things like that that we do
tend to experience when we're taking
from the material
and we are also just
investigating some options to improve
the
um the pumping system that we that we
use when we taped from the tower river
which will allow us to to blend the
water um at the moment the way that the
infrastructure set up we either have to
take
um 100 of our water from the pleura dam
or 100 from the tower river so we're
hoping that we can change that pumping
arrangement and get a blended source
when when we needed to
we don't have to go to the material
river very often
but it is something that we are mindful
of
that's a good answer of that um
thank you very much
neville you've got a question
thank you mr chair i've just got a
question made on
i see in the report about the peak
demand and how you'd
asked
or monitoring with the
preferred tenders about
not doing the preserved work during the
during air high capacity
was there any sort of come comeback in
that or is it going to be any extra cost
because of that
uh no i i don't believe so the uh
the proposals that we were seeing that
were received um have have allowed to
accommodate that and they certainly
haven't raised any issue with it
so
i don't believe it's a major issue for
them
we could potentially have i'm not sure
if we can have a discussion about it in
open committee um but potentially in
closed committee might be more
appropriate
thank you you can rise at the end thank
you
okay
just miss geneva for me this is a good
example of a project going back to
michael's question
of one where we felt uh it's very
important
but it could be lost in the ruck of
three waters reform and we wanted to get
it done
before three waters reform and so we're
fully compliant with drinking water
standards both matera and gore
thank you miss chief executive so
water quality is a
an ongoing
oh
a priority in the gore district
with that i'll move that we
received the report thank you for the
report call for a second to please
thank you stuart those in favor please
say i
against it's carried
item six gore multi-sports complex
improvement project it was one of those
opportunities through the shovel really
projects
the council
took advantage of and received a
substantial amount of money from central
government to upgrade some improvement
work and
it appears that this is all but
completed and been completed
successfully
um
oh matt i'll hand over to you for a
brief rundown
uh through the chairman
um yeah it's a martin macarthur
multi-sports
manager prepared this report
so i haven't really been involved in it
too much so probably can't add too much
but i guess as you'll see from his
report everything appears to be on track
and tracking well so i'm not sure mr
perry
yeah mr chairman um we are in the home
straight um so the roof
has been substantially completed now
since well
earlier this year it's a ventilation
project that was held up through a
resource consenting process
uh and designed the pad to actually
accommodate the the new unit we've
already bought
but it's all now starting to come
together and i said the the project is
due to finish in the end of october
and i feel pretty proud really that we
are two
project
sorry shovel ready uh projects uh
nearing completion with the big library
and community rooms refurbishment next
door uh due to be finished around about
january so i think we've as a council
has certainly fulfilled our part of the
bargain
um
and it's
and for the multi-sports complex it
really was um a bit of a godsend because
the event center roof was um
in poor condition even though it's only
10 years old and that's money that we
would have had to be fined through
ratepayers
from what is already uh a fully taxed
kappa works program so um i think this
the staff and martin particularly has
done a fantastic job in
corralling the different aspects of this
project bear in mind that um
hashem i won't try and pronounce the
second name i can't call it but he left
in last october and so martin has had to
really run this project along with staff
shortages at the pool
and done a great job in my view
thank you mr perry um yeah i've got a
couple of comments no doubt about it
this this
demonstratively are pretty nimble of
organizations particularly when there's
an opportunity to get money from central
government to do work
um so congratulations mr chief executive
i don't think anybody else in the local
government is
even in the hunt
when it comes to
scavenging uh
finance from central government to
complete work
um
just to call me yes the multi-sports
great facility 10 years old
but i guess it is a
it is something for me that
the original
organization that wasn't
a council organization that completed
this work
it's it's shown us that
cutting the odd corner here and there
is not successful so council has been
able to come in and
and
[Music]
make good some of those little things
and they
so that the
project will
be in good heart for many years to come
so we are done always concerned any
questions comments
before we close off that item
thank you michael would you like to move
or receive the report michael
on behalf of michael i will remove that
we reach sector report
and call for a second though
uh thinking all those in favor please
like
those against this carried
we need to actually um find out about
that michael because it would be good if
you did have that ability
mr perry
i like to check that out michael i
thought you were a fully fledged member
but um
we don't see you with a uh a learner
sticker on your forehead um so
um
in my humble view you should be a full
member because the idea was to cross
pollinate the membership of both uh
order and risk and capital works
particularly in respect of the
independent members on both those
committees so look into that
thank you mr perry michael it looks like
you got a job
item seven i haven't skipped one have i
hillbray hillbury avenue
reservoir replacement project
um another complex
project the the old reservoir
aside from the water tear
is is is um
old
and needs to be replaced and i guess
it's
come to council attention is just this
suite of works
where councils concentrating on
upgrading essential infrastructure and
water water services um there's uh
a report would somebody like to
speak to the report think you met
yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah so
obviously um council considered a report
in july
after some
concerns have been raised by a
structural engineer regarding the
hilbert avenue water tower
and potential for
debris to fall from the tower
and as a result of that the council has
decided to demolish the water tower
and and as part of that we need to
construct a new pump station shed
to house existing pumps
that are currently located in the water
tower
um
i guess
some some preliminary works have been
completed um just to make sure that we
we appropriately manage the
um health and safety risks to staff
going onto that site in the short term
um so quite comfortable with with that
risk now
um
and then we will go through and
complete the design of the necessary
pump shed and get that works completed
before then demolishing the
water tower um
yeah so happy to take any questions on
that
i've just got a question thanks mister
through the chair is it
um
i see you in the last at the last column
on page 25
and you've done a bit of modelling and
you think that
you may have to expand the capacity of
the pumps and i see that you're building
the shed
to accommodate that
but what i'm thinking is that
why are we going to go to this expense
of putting the old pumps back into that
we shed and then possibly
having to expand the pumps
maybe in a very short space of time that
that we may need to
why aren't we just saying that okay the
total cost of expanding et cetera is
this amount
and then
the three waters with reform may be that
it's part of that aspect is that this is
going to be the total cost
and then it's all done and dusted right
from the word go
yeah through the chair thanks for that
it's good question um
i mean i guess the first thing um
to note is that
the
the modeling that that's been done
is based on predicted growth but there's
probably not a huge amount of certainty
as to
when or if that will occur
so
if you took that approach you could do
some upgrades and then
not
not get any benefit for a long time and
it could be potentially quite
significantly oversized
um
i guess it would be different if you
were putting in new pumps
um
in which case you might go down that
approach
but because we've got existing pumps
that are in good condition um we see it
as in in terms of transferring those
pumps that we set as as being a
relatively
easy
in
low-cost exercise
um and as long as we we design the pump
station to accommodate the the larger
pumps in the future then we can do that
as and when required and we still get
the full use out of the existing pumps
rather than
throwing them away
earlier than
they need to be
it's something that we'll probably give
a bit more consideration too
as as the project develops
but
i
yeah i guess i see it as as potentially
adding cost where we might not actually
need need it in the future
but certainly we need to make that
provision for it
uh so they were installed in
2008 or 2009 so yeah coming about about
12 12 years so there's three existing
pumps um
only one runs at a time so there's
plenty of
standby
pumping there um and and we don't have
any issues with all three of the pumps
so that
you know
we're expecting to get a reasonable
amount of time out of them yet
so if we follow this timeline in uh
just over a year
or 14 months
the water tear will be gone
that's correct
questions comments
so the the demolition um we're looking
at
putting that out to tender
[Music]
uh probably in the
second quarter of 2023 so around
march april 2023 so we just want to make
sure that we have certainty around
the pump relocation and timing of that
before we go out to tinder
and it also aligns with the the funding
allocation
um
to to then have the work completed in 23
financial year
i guess just on that there has been a
reasonable level of interest around the
demolition contract um and a number of
contractors get in contact with me so
because i'm feeling really reasonably
positive around getting a number of
proposals and hopefully some
cost-effective proposals to to do that
work
councillor phillips
thank you mr chair uh just a question
then
are you going to do it before the bridge
is built
or after
uh
through the chair
yeah so there's nothing stopping us
demolishing the water tower um before we
have a pipeline between escort and
hillbury it's the the reservoir
that needs the pipeline first so
certainly the plan is to
put the pipeline in
whatever
form that might take
across the river
and then
then we'll already have the the water
tower demolished
and at that point we'll be right to to
replace the reservoir
i'll wait with interest because you
haven't convinced me
why you're going to remain on council
but yes we'll it uh
we'll have continued discussions
look i i'm moved that we received that
report and uh there'll be some more
discussion
in part b and call for a second uh
i'll even call on neville to second that
i'm sorry nick i didn't see you i'll get
you next time
those in favor please say aye
against it's carried
and that completes the public
um
part of
this committee meeting and i will now
move
that we go into
public excluded